Steve Souders:
I'm Steve Souders.
I work here
at Google on latency.
And I'm very excited to have
John Resig here today.
He lives in Boston
but works for Mozilla.
So every once in a while
he's out here,
and I asked him
a few months ago
to let me know
when he was coming out,
so we could get him to come
to Google and do a tech talk.
For people who don't know,
John is the creator of jQuery.
He works at Mozilla
as a JavaScript evangelist.
He's an author; he wrote
Pro JavaScript Techniques.
And now he's working on...
Secrets
of the JavaScript Ninja.
And, um, every once
in a while,
I get these...
basking-in-the-warm-glow moments
at conferences
because I'm surrounded
by people like John
who are at the forefront
of Web development today.
And you can really see how much
they're personally putting
into the work that they do.
So, in addition to his work
with Mozilla
and Firefox and jQuery,
John also works on Firebug,
is pretty much leading
the Mozilla contributions
to Firebug.
Uh, he, I think, just--
his FireUnit released.
FireUnit just came out.
Um, and so we're all
in good hands
with people like John
in the lead.
Um, John, so I wanted
to present you with this bag
of Google goodies.
Resig: Thank you.
man: And then I'll take that
away from you
so you don't have to hold it.
And, without any further ado,
please help me welcome
John Resig.
[applause]
Resig: So I want to thank you
all for coming out today.
I really appreciate it.
So I wanted to talk
about a couple things today.
Specifically, I wanted to talk
about pretty much
all the new things
that are coming in browsers
and the latest releases
of browsers.
And I wanted to look at all
the performance improvements,
especially related to JavaScript
and the DOM,
and all the new APIs
that are starting to land.
You know, trickle down
from like HTML 5
and the new W3C specs.
So a lot of my time lately,
at least with Mozilla,
has been spent working
on this performance suite
called Dromaeo.
And this is a test suite
for doing performance analysis
on JavaScript and DOM
with a browser.
And doing this has really opened
my eyes to this issues
that browser developers and,
you know, implementers face
when they deal with all these,
you know, minutiae
in these APIs.
So it's really--I find it to be
really interesting.
So I wanted to talk about some
of the upcoming browsers here
that are on their way out
and should be hitting the
streets here relatively soon.
So there's...
Firefox 3.1 coming out here
in just a little bit.
And Safari 4, IE 8, Opera 10,
and then the next release
of Chrome.
Um, but the big thing
that is common
amongst all these browsers
is that they are all actively
iterating and rapidly improving
their performance.
And this is--
this is really huge,
and it's really exciting.
It's a great time
to be developing.
So I wanted
to just quickly draw through
some of the new, big things
that are gonna be
in these browsers
coming up.
Um, and as I talk
about some of these APIs,
please, if you have
a question, raise your hand
so we can cover it
a little bit more in depth.
But, um, so Firefox 3.1,
it's currently scheduled
to come out here
pretty soon.
Beta 3 is gonna be coming out,
I think,
within just
the next couple weeks.
And, but a lot of the big things
is that it's gonna be
much, much faster
than Firefox 3.
There's a whole new
JavaScript engine landing.
There's the new video
and audio tags,
which has been
in the news recently.
And private browsing.
Private browsing is
another feature
that sort of just all browsers
are implementing it
pretty much simultaneously now.
Uh, Safari 4.
The actual release date
isn't quite public yet,
but it's pretty much assumed
that it's gonna be coming out
whenever 10.6 comes out.
Big things are that it's gonna
be completely ACID 3 compliant.
It's gonna be much, much faster,
even faster than before,
and it's gonna have
this new concept of being able
to deploy Web applications
to your desktop.
You can--I showed you
a little menu up here
where you can now do
a "Save as Web Application."
You can take a Web page
and save it to your desktop
and then load it up again
in sort of a quasi-offline mode.
A lot of this is gonna be made
possible
by the new HTML 5 offline
portion of the specification.
And that's really great
in of itself.
IE 8 is--this one's also coming
out here really soon.
They just released
the new release candidate.
But even--
while the performance of IE 8
doesn't really, I wanna say,
compare to, you know,
what's happening in Firefox
and Chrome and WebKit,
it's dramatically faster than
their previous release IE 7.
And, at the same time,
they are now doing
what's called process per tab.
And this--
in Chrome as well--
but the concept
that each individual tab
is running
in a separate process,
rather than in a thread,
like what happens
in Firefox
and WebKit for Safari.
The--yes.
employee: [inaudible]
Resig: Okay, so the question
was--when Steve looked at it,
it looked
like it was two processes:
one for Chrome,
one for all tabs.
Um, I'm not sure exactly.
At least
from what Microsoft has said
that they were splitting it up--
maybe by splitting up
was only splitting twice.
I know, at least
within the case of Chrome,
it's definitely split
per tab.
So...
I would not be surprised
it's only split twice.
Opera 10, the release date
for Opera 10 is not solid yet.
They haven't made
any big announcements.
A beta just came out recently.
Another big--they are, as well,
are shooting
for full ACID 3 compliance
and video and audio tag
amongst some other APIs.
And hopefully a new UI skin
as well.
Um, and then,
Google Chrome.
I'm sure everyone here is
well familiar with it.
Um, but the new release here
should be coming out
relatively soon,
but the big things--
the big thing
that it really popularized
was this process per tab.
And this has really helped
to change
how developers are able
to look at Web applications.
'Cause right now
browsers, generally,
they have everything
in just a single process.
Everything, you know,
each tab is split up
amongst multiple threads,
and they're all handling
different things.
One might be handling rendering
or doing networking or...
And the problem with that is
there's a tendency
for a lot of collision
to occur.
And if one tab is slowing down,
consuming a lot of resources--
one page is consuming
a lot of resources,
your other tabs will be blocked.
So with this new process per tab
model,
you start to confine everything,
uh, extremely.
So what you end up having to do
is you sacrifice memory
for the benefit
of performance.
Um, but, so at the very least,
it's resulting in some--
you can run some really
heavy-duty Web applications
without interfering with
whatever else is going on.
One thing that I really liked
about Chrome, though,
was the fact
that you could monitor
each individual tab
and see how much memory
and resources
each tab was consuming.
They included
this--this view.
It's almost
like a Windows Task Manager
but within Chrome itself.
And that was very eye-opening.
Because most Web developers
have no idea
how much their Web site--
what their Web sites
are actually, you know,
affecting the outside world.
You know, they have no idea
if their Web site's, you know,
consuming 40 megabytes of RAM
or, you know, 140.
And it's really important
to know that
if you want to do
a Web application
that is actually going to be
deployed, you know, widely.
A couple of other changes
that happened here
with Chrome,
and they changed it such
that timers can now run
at rates faster than normal.
I know Mike Belshe is here.
And he was responsible
for this.
But this is very interesting
because typically browsers have
a floor for how quickly
a timer can run.
It's usually around
13 milliseconds or so,
how quickly it can be called
over and over again.
What that means is
is that it's limiting
the number of times--
let's say your frame rate
for an animation
or, you know, the number of
times to pre-read
a particular object
or what have you.
But what happened is now
that they've moved
into a process per tab model,
you can now give a tab
the ability to just check
as frequently as it needs to
or update the page
and without fear of it blocking
the resources of the other tabs.
So this is really nice
because now you can get
insanely high frame rates
in Chrome, for example,
where you just do animations
at, you know, many hundreds
of frames per second,
which is really quite exciting.
Um...
So I wanted to talk
a little bit
about the new JavaScript
engines.
So there's
three new Java Script engines
that are coming out here in,
or are in various stages
of release, in WebKit,
WebKit Safari, and Firefox,
and in Chrome.
And they're--so Firefox has...
well, I should say
that all of them
are competing very, very heavily
at this point.
But this is really fantastic
in my opinion.
Because when these browser
vendors compete
and all try
to one-up each other
for a performance,
the end result is
that users just get
a better experience.
The users--you know,
the pages load faster.
You have developers--
their applications run faster.
You know, everyone wins
so it's really great.
I hope they keep battling it out
indefinitely.
But all these engines have
a couple common features.
At this point,
they all have virtual machines
of some sort
so that they can run
some sort
of optimized bytecode...
representation
of the JavaScript.
And additionally they also
almost all at this point
do some sort of shaping.
So looking at objects
to determine their general feel
and structure
and being able to do--
be able to do things
based upon that.
So here's
just sort of a rough structure
of how the engines currently
break down.
I mean, when you write
your JavaScript code,
you end up having--
it ends up going
through multiple steps
before finally
and eventually executing.
But the result is, though,
is that these engines
are breaking down
into this, you know,
lower bytecode layer.
They're able to optimize their
engines much more dramatically
and, you know, make tweaks
that just unleash performance.
I want to talk about this
a little bit
because--
just to give an example here--
This is my pseudo bytecode.
This is not 100% accurate,
just to give you an idea.
So, like, if you have
a very simple operation,
you're adding
two variables together.
The problem is
is that in JavaScript
there is a lot of ambiguity.
You know, when you add
two variables together,
you may be concatenating 'em
if one of them is a string
or, you know,
if they're numbers,
if they're both numbers,
then you'll be adding 'em.
So--and you need to, like,
underneath the hood,
all these options--
all these checks are occurring.
You know, it's checking
if each variable's a string,
and if so,
concatenating 'em together.
If neither of 'em's a string,
then it's gonna add them
together.
And then, well, then you just
concat and add.
There's a whole other set
of options
that have to be executed.
But the nice thing
is that they're starting
to do some optimization here,
so--what's roughly called
shaping--
so that they can determine
if an object is--
you know, if it looks
like a string,
and if it probably is a string,
then make some assumptions
and remove
some of these checks.
So even here--
so like if we were trying
to get the method property
of an object,
there are a huge number
of checks that have to be done
simply before we can even get
the property,
and that's even
before actually executing it.
But if we do
some sort of shaping,
all this code ends up boiling
down to a simple, you know,
couple pieces
of bytecode operation
rather than, you know,
dozens and dozens of execution
just to access
a single property.
So all of this optimization
is dramatically improving
the performance
of Web pages
and on test suites.
So I just wanted to talk
a little bit
about some of the engines
in particular.
There is TraceMonkey.
This is the new engine
released by Mozilla
replacing the old engine
SpiderMonkey.
It's a variation
of SpiderMonkey.
And this one is--
uses what's called
tracing technology to optimize
commonly repeating patterns,
things that happen
again and again.
So, for example,
if you had some loop
that was iterating
1,000 times
and it was calling
some function within that loop,
what it might do is remove
some of the costly bytecode
checks that need to occur,
making sure, for example,
the letter--
the variable i--
making--
it's probably gonna continue
to be a number
throughout the lifespan
of this loop.
So removing--you know,
just making assumptions,
assuming that i's gonna remain
a number,
that, you know, optimizing,
adding one to the variable i.
All of these things.
And so that when these loops
start to occur
and when it starts
to go through
and iterate back and forth,
back and forth,
it can start
to remove that
and optimize it down,
especially with inlining
some of the function calls.
So, taking
these external functions,
pulling the code out of them,
and essentially inlining
them into a single block.
So that way it ends up being
just so much faster.
You know, an empty loop--
I remember seeing
some numbers that an empty loop
running in TraceMonkey
was comparable to the speed
of the [indistinct] you can see.
Of course, that means
pretty much nothing
since you're just doing
an empty loop
but the important part here is
that it's trying to strip away
as much extraneous stuff
as possible.
Which is really good.
So SquirrelFish, the WebKit team
did all sorts of work
to get good just-in-time
compilation working
for their JavaScript engine.
And they did a lot of work
on their bytecode
and optimizing their bytecode.
And you can especially see this
in their--in the performance
on regular expressions.
The regular expression
performances is
pretty much insane.
And they basically did
all sorts of optimization there
in making that fast.
Then Chrome V8, they--
in their engine
they did a lot of work
in doing more shaping,
which I talked about earlier.
But that allowed them to do
just really fast
property lookups on objects.
And it was really
quite impressive
when it was released.
So there's a lot
of difficulty
in trying to get
an accurate measure
of performance,
trying to understand
what exactly makes
a piece of JavaScript code
accurate and representative
of JavaScript code as a whole.
And especially so, does
optimizing this piece of code--
will it actually help users?
So there are
a couple test suites right now,
each released
by the different vendors,
and there's the SunSpider
test suite released by WebKit
that includes a number
of different tests
for testing pure JavaScript.
Uh, the V8 Benchmark,
which was released
at the same time as V8,
that also includes
a number of pure JavaScript
tests.
Then the Dromaeo tests
that I wrote and released,
and this WebKit contains
a mix of JavaScript tests
and DOM tests,
and it actually includes
both the SunSpider
and V8 Benchmarks as well.
Just to show some numbers,
these are outdated
at this point.
I don't think it would be
possible to give you numbers
that were even up-to-date
since everything changes
every single night.
But the important part here
is that performance
of old browsers used to be,
like, IE 7 level of performance
and, like, I mean,
if you look at the difference
between these couple browsers
on the left,
it's miniscule
in comparison.
I think these numbers are
a couple months out of date
at this point.
I mean, everything has just
gotten so dramatically faster
in the last couple months
even
that it's really just blowing
away.
So this is
on the Chrome Benchmark.
It's not completely clear
if the Chrome guys just happened
to be really, really good
at their Benchmark
or if they optimized
for the Benchmark.
But, regardless,
they do really good
in their Benchmark.
And then on Dromaeo
as well.
This one--again, this one tests
a mixture of JavaScript
and DOM.
All right, so wanted to talk
about some
of the new improvements
that are coming
outside of JavaScript engines
in particular.
Steve Souders released--
sitting right there--
released an excellent tool
for helping
browser developers determine
what exactly is going on
at the...
for loading items
over the network and browsers.
And it's his UA tool--
I provide the URL there.
But this is a rough breakdown
of the number of features--
he breaks it down into a number
of different categories,
which I'll go into here
in a second,
and shows how well
each browser passes that.
Um, for example,
for simultaneous connections,
some meaning that,
if you have a number
of images in your page,
how many, you know, images can
be downloaded simultaneously?
So the higher that number is,
you know, theoretically
the faster
a page is gonna be able
to load.
Um, and you can see
the steps in improvement here.
Older browsers, Firefox 2, IE 6,
IE 7,
they all have a maximum
connection number of two.
But as browsers, you know,
start to increase here,
you see it goes up to four
in Safari
and then other browsers,
you know, Firefox 3 and Opera,
all have six to seven
connections,
simultaneous connections.
And I should say simultaneous
connections per domain.
A maximum number
of connections, is
so that, you know,
if you have images being loaded
from multiple domains,
you know,
how many can you be doing
at a time?
And that's really high.
So we're talking anywhere
from 25 to 60
simultaneous connections.
Um, another big thing
is being able to download
scripts in parallel
so that if you have two scripts
in a page, and, you know,
they both take, you know,
200 milliseconds
to download over the network,
that it won't take
400 seconds total.
Instead, it'll just take
200 seconds--
sorry, 200 milliseconds--since
they downloaded simultaneously
and then execute
back to back.
Um, there's another thing
that's starting to be
implemented more widely.
There's--it's called
the defer script.
And this is actually gonna be
in Firefox 3.1.
It's in Internet Explorer,
and it's also in Opera.
And it allows you to say
that, given this script,
to load it, you know,
asynchronously,
and then execute it again
at a later time.
It doesn't matter
when this script executes.
But, additionally,
there's some properties
of a deferred script.
Like, it can still
document.write,
and when it document.writes,
it still does it
in the correct location
of the document.
Things like that.
So, but when browsers start
to implement this,
you're gonna be able
to put this defer script
on things like ads,
and the ads would be loaded--
would be deferred-loaded
and then injected
into the document, you know,
when they're finished loading,
as opposed to blocking
the entire document load.
Another big thing that browsers
are getting better at
is redirect caching.
So every time you access
a Web site,
redirects occur
from adding in slashes
or going to a document page.
This can, you know,
it adds up.
It's another network request.
And some browsers are getting
better at this,
like Chrome and Firefox.
They're caching these redirects
so they don't have to be done
over and over again.
It's a tiny--
it seems really tiny,
but it's little things
like this that really add up.
And optimizing these and fixing
them can really improve
the performance
of a Web application.
So this is a nice thing.
It's called link prefetching.
And it allows you to pre-load
resources on your site
so that you can say
that at some point later on
I'm gonna use this image.
You're telling the browser,
load this ahead of time
so that the user doesn't have
to watch it load
whenever it pops in.
So this is something
relatively new.
And right now it's only
implemented in Firefox.
But it's generally
a much better way
of managing this,
as opposed to having
to go through JavaScript
and using JavaScript
to manage, you know, all this
downloading and prefetching
in the background.
All right. Any questions
before I keep going on?
Yes.
employee: [inaudible]
Resig: So the question was
"How is the performance
of JavaScript parse time
increased?"
So right now the test suites--
I should say--
so out
of the different test suites,
currently only SunSpider tests
parse time.
But they don't test it separate
from actual execution time.
It's all clumped together.
So it's currently--currently no
suite analyzes just parse time
versus, you know,
the total execution time.
That is absolutely something
that should be analyzed
since that affects
the initial load.
You know, we wanna make sure
that, you know,
when that first hit occurs,
you got 200k of JavaScript
that gets parsed really fast.
Um, so it's not completely clear
what the best ways
of analyzing that are simply
because it's not something
that can be easily done
in a browser context.
You might have to move
to a command line context,
and, at that point,
you know, if you're measuring
on the command line, you know,
is that really
a realistic test since you're
not in a browser anymore?
There's a lot of questions,
but I agree
there's not a good test there
yet.
Yes.
employee: [inaudible]
Resig: So, just to repeat,
so is this, you know, JITing,
does it, you know, slow down
this initial load,
and, you know, is this cached?
So at least
in my experience,
looking at the numbers, the
JITing does not significantly
slow down performance.
At least not in a way
that the browser vendors
are concerned about
because it ultimately wins
much, much more later on.
But the--as far as caching,
as I understand it,
most cache within a page
but not from page to page.
You know,
once you leave a page,
you're pretty much done.
It depends how much sharing
of execution context there is
simply because--I guess
that might be a case
where, you know, a threaded
environment might work better
since they all know what's going
on with the other processes.
employee: [inaudible]
Resig: Yeah,
so that's another question is,
if you're pulling something
that's obviously
an identical piece of code
every single time, you know,
jQuery or Dojo, YUI.
You know, it's, um,
you know--
if there was a way to send down
a straight bytecode,
you know, just say,
"Hey, here's the lowest level
you can get,"
but, at the same time,
that would require
that all the browsers
standardized
in a single bytecode.
And they're having
a hard enough time standardizing
in just JavaScript,
so, I mean, we'll see.
Um, right there.
employee: [inaudible]
Resig: I couldn't say.
I wouldn't feel comfortable
giving a good estimate,
um, until I had good data.
I mean, at least,
you know, this parse time
is...
at least, right now, at best,
it's just clumped in
with execution time.
employee: [inaudible]
Resig: Um, yeah, so the question
was "If it's found out
"that parse time is
a significant burden,
that's something
that should be optimized."
You know, I assume
that if solid numbers come out
for all the major
JavaScript engines,
you better believe that the
browsers are gonna be working
to optimize that number.
For developers,
I'm not sure.
I mean, then again,
that's another case
where better tooling would help,
you know,
to answer those questions.
Yes.
employee: [inaudible]
man: Could you repeat
the question
for the remote sites?
Resig: Yeah, when he's done.
employee: [inaudible]
Okay, so, just to repeat,
so the--
at this point
with the new engines,
the vast majority of time
isn't spent parsing.
In fact, very little time
is spent parsing.
And that these new engines
are trying to be
as just fundamentally lazy
as possible
to try and break parsing out
later
and worry
about everything later.
And, so, I mean,
there may be an initial hit,
but it definitely isn't,
you know, a massive hit.
At least not in comparison
to old engines.
employee: [inaudible]
Resig: So just that...
yeah, right.
So that the initial parsing
in JITing isn't free,
but, you know, the ultimate win
you get is pretty awesome, so...
Okay, any more questions?
All right.
All right, so I wanted to talk
a little bit
about the communication layer,
some new communication APIs
that are landing.
One of the ones that's actually
being implemented quite widely
is postMessage.
This method allows you to--
it exists on windows
and allows you to communicate
from one window to another.
So, like from a page
to an iframe.
You know, an iframe
to a parent page.
Things of that nature.
But what's so good about it
is that it works across domain.
It doesn't matter, you know,
if the frames are owned
by different domains.
So, for example, if you had
an iframe on your page,
you could send it
a text message, you know, test
or what have you
and a URL.
The URL specifies--you're
saying, "Send this message
to this iframe
only if it matches this URL."
The iframe then would then
listen for messages
to get passed into it
from postMessage.
And so it listens
for a message event
and then verifies the origin
of the incoming message.
You know, makes sure that the
message is coming from a domain
that it trusts,
and, if not, you know,
just stops doing
whatever it was gonna do
but otherwise uses the data
that's coming in.
So using postMessage,
you can implement
all sorts of interesting things.
In some personal experiments
of mine,
I've used postMessage
to implement, you know,
a cross-domain XMLHttpRequest
because you just insert
a little iframe,
you start doing communication
back and forth.
And it becomes, you know,
very usable.
So this is, I think,
a very interesting new API.
Then there's true cross-domain
XMLHttpRequest.
This is using
the W3C Access Control API.
And if on--
so what you do is you use
XMLHttpRequest as normal,
and you would try
to request
a remote document.
It verifies if certain headers
are in place
that will allow a piece
of XML, HTML, what have you
to be requested.
So in the case
of the Access Control,
you can specify,
for example,
Access-Control-Allow-Origin.
And then you can specify
a single URL,
so it'll, say, you know,
only allow things
that come from Google,
only allow requests that come
from Google,
or, in this case, star,
allow requests to come
from everywhere.
And you can really filter down
this way.
So what's interesting is that
this new Access Control
specification is starting
to be used, like, everywhere
within the specifications
within HTML 5.
And it's very likely
that--there's still a lot
of debate, I should say,
over whether or not
this should be specified
for like audio and video tags--
so that if you want to include
a remote video,
that, you know, does it have
to have these headers
to allow you to access
that video?
It's not really clear
at this point.
employee: [inaudible]
Resig: Uh, so, yeah, this is
the response header, correct.
So in this case, yeah,
if you had an HTML page
on a remote domain and you
tacked on that extra header,
you would be able to--
any browser that supported
this cross-domain XHR
would be able to request it.
Yeah.
Um, there's some
decent improvements coming
in DOM Navigation.
One of the early ones to land
was getElementsByClassName,
you know, allowing you
to find all sorts of--
you know, find elements on page
that have a specified class.
This is in some current
browsers: Safari 3.1,
Firefox 3.0, and Opera 9.6.
We just found a bug,
just the other day,
in Opera's implementation.
It's unable to find--
actually, this example here
doesn't work in Opera 9.6.
Uh, it's not able to find the
second class in a class name.
For whatever reason,
it can only find the first one.
So, yeah, it's still a work
in progress.
But at the very least,
it's very fast.
It's way, way faster.
Just to show you...
So like on the left--
on the right here,
we have some old school methods,
just pure JavaScript DOM.
We have an XPath implementation,
but then there's the native
getElementsByClassName,
and it's a tiny, tiny fraction
of the normal cost.
And simply because of that,
JavaScript frameworks
that take advantage of it
are instantly sped up.
And, you know, using it
in your code is,
you know, it's a huge win.
One of the things
I'm really excited about now
is the new Selectors API.
This is the W3C specification,
Selectors API specification.
And it gives you new methods
for finding elements on a page
using CSS selectors.
And so it's good because you get
the best of both worlds.
You get an intuitive syntax.
You know, developers already
familiar with CSS rules,
you know,
for how they match elements--
and, you know,
at the same time,
you get just crazy, crazy speed.
I'm really excited by the fact
that it's--
everyone's implementing it.
It's implemented in IE 8,
Opera 10...
it's gonna be in Firefox 3.1,
in Safari 4.
It's everywhere,
and I'm really excited by that.
This is to show you
some performance.
On the left here we have
some traditional
JavaScript libraries
that are just using
regular JavaScript quer--
you know, JavaScript DOM.
Then on the right is
querySelectorAll.
And it's a tenth--
you know, it's ten times faster
than the next closest library.
Of course, all the libraries now
are adopting querySelectorAll,
since it makes
a ton of sense to.
So that's gonna be really great.
One of the new specifications
that's just finishing up
and starting to land in browsers
is called the Traversal API.
Again, this is
a W3C specification.
It's implemented in Firefox 3.1.
But it gives you
a couple methods you can use
to make navigating
around a DOM document easier.
Roughly, it makes it so you can
access element siblings.
'Cause traditionally there's--
if you access, you know,
firstChild or lastChild
or, you know, what have you,
you could get a comment node,
you could get a text node,
you could get
any number of these things.
And when--a lot of the time
developers just want to get
the elements
that are there,
since that's usually
what's visible.
So those four things
are in the specification.
They just landed
in Firefox 3.1.
But one of the things that's
unrelated to that specification
is .children.
This was something that was
originally in Internet Explorer.
But it is now implemented
in every browser.
Every browser now implements it
and allows you to get
only the child elements
of a parent element.
And so, I mean,
in a lot of ways,
having .children around
kind of removes the need
for this new specification.
But the nice thing
is that in Firefox 3.1,
they actually implement
.children,
so now it'll be
absolutely everywhere.
All right, so drag and drop.
There's--some browsers are
actually starting
to implement the HTML 5 style
of drag and drop.
There's--you get all sorts
of messages to indicate,
you know, events to indicate
when dragging is occurring,
starting, and stopping.
And you can hook into this
and transfer data
from different points
in the document.
It's pretty cool
and something that really should
have been done a long time ago.
So we're starting
to see this now start
to land in browsers.
But in the meantime
we're kinda stuck
since not everyone implements
yet.
But in the meantime
we can use
getBoundingClientRect.
This is a method
that is starting
to get implemented more.
This is
an Internet Explorer method,
historically.
And it's starting to get
implemented more
in more browsers.
And what it allows you to do
is it allows you to find--
get a pretty accurate
representation of the position
of an element
in a document.
And when you're doing
drag and drop,
you need to determine
pretty accurately
where that element
is currently located
so that you can move it
accurately
and so that you can position it
well.
And so it's really fast,
and it's starting
to get implemented more,
which is awesome.
Another great thing
that I'm really excited about
is the inclusion
of threading in JavaScript.
This is just starting
to come out here.
And it's really, really exciting
to see this land.
So what it's called--
it's called Web Workers.
And it's not threading
in the true sense.
But what you can do
is you can spawn scripts
that can run in the background,
and you can communicate
with them
and, you know,
using message passing.
So just to show you
a simple example,
here we have a script
being loaded in externally,
so in this case, it loads
into myWorker script file
and executes it
in the background.
Then, at the same time, whenever
the worker is done executing,
a message will get passed back
to the message callback.
So you can start to communicate
back and forth
with these scripts
that are getting loaded
in these workers.
I just wanted to show
an example.
So this is done
by Oliver Hunt.
He's on the WebKit SquirrelFish
team.
And he built a raytracer
in JavaScript.
So I'm just gonna disable this.
So right now,
it's using the canvas element
to draw.
If we run this,
we can see it truck along.
So this is
just regular JavaScript
communicating with Canvas,
you know,
doing all the calculation,
and drawing everything out.
It takes a while.
It is...
even in this right here,
this is Safari nightly.
It's still gonna take, I'd say,
about 15, 20 seconds to run.
So once that finishes...
Okay, 27 seconds.
All right, so let's reload,
and let's add in
a couple worker threads.
So what that's gonna do,
it's gonna break apart
different portions
of the image to render,
send it to each
of the workers,
so that when they're done,
it'll report back and draw them.
So let's run this now.
There we go.
All the worker threads did it
in 3 1/2 seconds.
So almost ten times faster.
And that was
with only four worker threads.
We can probably up that
a little bit,
figure out a sweet spot.
[a cough and laughter]
Say what?
employee: [inaudible]
Resig: I don't know.
He was asking, "Is it because
of a set time out or something?"
Not sure.
I'm not...
I'm not sure what the--like I
was talking to him before
about his implementation
about why, you know,
I guess--here, I guess we can go
down to one worker thread.
We can't really see it.
It's not exciting.
Hang on.
So my guess, maybe just
the other implementation
he had was just bad,
maybe.
But even so,
using one worker thread
took 6 1/2 seconds.
Four worker threads was able
to speed it up to 3 1/2.
So there's a definite room
for speedup.
Unfortunately, there are a lot
of gotchas
with this new worker thread
stuff,
one of which is
that when you pass messages
to one of these workers,
it has to be as a string.
A nice thing, though, is--I'm
glad they started to do this--
that if you pass in
a JavaScript object,
it'll serialize it
as JSON
and then deserialize it
again.
So the important thing here
is that they wanted to make sure
there could be
no information leak.
No access to external windows
or anything
that an inner thread
shouldn't have access to.
And, additionally, these inner
threads have a really limited...
existence, let's say.
They only have access
to basic JavaScript.
They don't have access
to the DOM,
they don't have access
to Canvas,
to any of this stuff.
So in the case
of these threads here,
what's really happening is
they're probably just pushing
around, you know, matrices
and numbers.
Then the main thread,
the one in the window,
is just, you know, is the one
that's actually doing
the rendering
to the canvas.
So...
[yawns]
I definitely hope
that at some point
we'll be able to pass around
canvas objects--
pass a canvas object
to a thread worker
and then have it come back
with some results.
That would be really awesome.
Any questions
on the worker thread stuff?
Okay, so...
there are a lot
of different, I guess,
CSS-related things
that started to get implemented,
and these are different stylings
and effects you can apply
to your site,
but while they don't provide
an immediate, obvious,
JavaScripty performance boost,
what they do is they allow you
to dramatically simplify
your markup and remove
all sorts of [indistinct]
you won't have to deal with
anymore.
One of the popular ones is--
one of the ones
that was implemented
really early
was the ability
to do rounded corners.
Traditionally, in order
to do rounded corners,
either required loading in
extra images
to represent the corners
or doing all sorts
of really nasty hacks
or lots of little divs
being spaced around.
And either way,
the old methods were not good.
But with the new CSS properties,
you can just add in corners
as part of your style sheet.
There's also the concept
of shadows.
Both having shadows on text,
so a drop shadow,
but being able to have shadows
around arbitrary elements.
So if you have a div
that's supposed to be hovering
somewhere on the page, you can
actually put a drop shadow
behind it now
and give that extra appearance.
And this is implemented
both in WebKit and Firefox.
See, I wanted to show...
I'll jump back
to the examples here real quick.
But there's also the ability
to load in custom fonts.
So right now most solutions
for loading in fonts
are usually, you know,
Flash-based.
Like there's sIFR
and other ones of that nature.
And they load in a font file
and render it
in a Flash context.
But what's starting to happen
is actually getting
some good font--
custom font support in CSS.
Let's see.
Oh, and then,
before I jump to the demo,
there's also
a new transformations
and animations
starting to land,
so WebKit has been really
pushing forward here.
It's starting to land
all sorts of new ways
to do animations
from CSS,
so no JavaScript involved
whatsoever.
And it's really quite exciting.
So let me show
some of these demos here.
This is an example
of the box shadows.
So these are
just normal little divs.
You know, you can resize it
and the shadows persist.
And these are all just styled
with this box shadow property.
Here we have Text-Shadow.
This guy made
a hilarious demo page
of things you should not do
with Text-Shadow.
And so he animated
the Text-Shadows,
and so added a fire style.
I like that one.
And then, you know, just showed
all sorts of ways--
using shadows,
you can get things that look
like they've been embossed
or things of that nature.
There's also the concept
of transformations.
So, in this case,
these are set to animate
when I move my mouse
over it
and then start to transform
an element.
So it transformed by position.
This is all CSS.
There's no JavaScript.
Rotate.
Grow in size.
And then you can also combine
properties.
So in this case it's actually
animating rounded corners,
color, and size
all at the same time.
Yeah, so it can get
pretty exciting.
I'm sure that'll be abused
in many, many ways.
[laughter]
And then here's an example
using custom loaded fonts.
So you can see
this is actual real text here.
And it's all being styled
using True Type fonts
that were dynamically loaded in.
Let me see if I can hard reload
here, so you can see the--
oh, yeah, it's all good.
Yeah, it just gets
all pulled in there.
Um, okay.
One of the things that I've been
most excited about lately
that's been getting
really good support in browsers
has been
the new HTML 5 canvas element.
And this new element allows--
essentially gives you
a 2D just box,
which you can draw.
You know, arbitrary shapes
and pixels and what have you.
But it gives you
a ton of power
to be able to actually draw
on a Web page.
And the things that people
have been doing with it
are really quite fantastic.
There's also a library
that was produced here at Google
called ExCanvas
that allows you to use Canvas
in other browsers--
oh, sorry, use Canvas
in processes
that don't support it
like Internet Explorer.
Unfortunately, it doesn't
support some of the new APIs,
like being able to do work
with matrices of pixels
and things of that nature.
I wanted to show
a quick demo.
I released early last year
something--
I ported the processing
visualization language
that was--it's a Java language.
I put it in Java,
and it allows you to do
all sorts of visualizations.
I ported it to a JavaScript
running inside a canvas.
I wanted to show
some examples here.
This is a simple one.
So this is just doing--
it's basic collision detection
and multiple objects
being rendered.
It's all in real time in a
canvas element using JavaScript.
Oh, let's see here.
Um...
So this one is actually--
oops--it's scanning
the pixels of an image and
rendering out the different--
it's going by pixel by pixel
through an image
that's loaded into a canvas and
drawing out the pixels of it.
Uh, let's see.
You can actually see
where exactly in the image
it's currently pulling from.
Let's see here.
I like this one.
This is a flock of birds.
So this is--you can really
start to see the performance
of these JavaScript engines.
So it's doing all
the computation to figure out
how the birds should be flocking
together
and then rendering them
simultaneously to the canvas.
I like this one too.
This is sort of a blobby shape
that you can play around with.
Yeah, I just have
way too much fun with this.
But I love Canvas.
I think it's definitely
one of the best things
that come out in Web development
as a whole.
Just showing you some examples
of what things you can do
with Canvas.
It gives you--
the important thing to realize
is that Canvas is not SVG.
You're not dealing
with vectors.
And you can't mutate shapes
once you draw them.
You can think of it
like Microsoft Paint.
You put it down, it's there, and
the only way to get rid of it
is to draw on top of it.
So you're constantly just--
you have some basic primitives
from drawing rectangles
and circles
and, you know,
things of that nature.
Then, when you draw it,
you can--you're given
a series of fills
and strokes.
You can fill a rectangle
with a color,
set a stroke
on the outline,
things like that.
Yes.
Okay, the thing that's nice
about Canvas, though,
is that it behaves just like
a normal HTML element.
You can embed it straight
in line.
It handles zIndex properly,
opacity.
It behaves completely normal,
so I've seen cases
where people have used canvases
to do things
like drop shadows
or rounded corners
for browsers
that don't have them.
Being able to draw
custom backgrounds
and all sorts of things
dynamically
using canvas elements.
There's really a lot
of possibilities.
Canvases themselves
can consume images,
so you can port
an image into a canvas.
And additionally,
in Firefox 3 and Safari 4,
which have the video element,
you'll be able to take
a frame of a video
and put it in a canvas element
and manipulate it, so that
that'll be pretty exciting.
One of the things that's
also seeing a lot of play
is the ability
to have better control
over data
on the client-side.
And one of the big things
has been the introduction
of some sort
of SQL storage
on the client-side.
And this was introduced
in HTML 5,
and it was implemented
in WebKit.
It gives you a full database,
so you can create a database
for a Web site and then run SQL
queries against it.
it's actually just a SQLite
implementation running
in the background.
I wanted to show
an example.
Just the other day, Brandon
Aaron contributed a jQuery.
He wrote a little API browser.
This is actually for the iPhone,
but...
You can browse
through the API,
and you can view methods
and whatnot.
But all of this information
was actually loaded up
in the background.
And it was actually stored
in a database.
So if you look here,
and this isn't the console,
you can see the database.
And here's--let's see.
Here we go.
I mean, it's a SQL database.
And you can go through
and see everything
that's powering the Web site.
Additionally, this works
on the iPhone as well.
So, in this case, when you first
loaded the application
on the iPhone,
it would download all the data,
store it in a SQL database
on the iPhone
so that it would be able
to load faster in the future.
And then--and then also there's
the native JSON support
starting to land
in JavaScript engines.
So this is giving you
the ability to parse JSON
and be able to convert JSON
or a JavaScript object
to a string and, you know,
just very, very quickly.
Just want to show you
the performance breakdown.
The yellow and purple lines
are traditional types
of parsing JSON--or I should
say, encoding and then decoding.
The red line, the one that has
virtually no spike to it,
is the native one,
so it's dramatically faster.
It's really quite excellent.
So I think I'm running
out of time,
so I just want
to quickly open up
for questions at this point
if anyone has any questions
about what I talked about
today.
Yeah.
employee: [inaudible]
So the question was
"Does it make sense
"to provide a strict mode
that will make it easier
for interpreters to analyze?"
Especially in the context
of JavaScript libraries.
I'm not completely sold on it.
I mean, the whole reason
for like a lot
of the old ECMAscript 4 stuff
was that there was
a huge assumption
that you weren't gonna be able
to make JavaScript fast
because JavaScript was--
it's a weird language.
It isn't statically typed.
And because of those--
and so they added things
like classes and types
and all sorts of things.
And then they found out that,
hey,
we can make JavaScript fast.
In fact, we can make JavaScript
really fast.
So I'm not really sold
on there being restrictions
to the language.
Especially
since current browsers seem
to be doing just fine anyway.
I think it'll only just limit
what you can do.
Yeah.
Another question? Yeah.
employee: [inaudible]
>> Resig: So he was saying
that the performance is getting
much faster,
but the tools we have
for understanding it
just aren't there yet
of what's available.
So, I mean, it's incredibly
difficult at this moment.
I think one of the big things
going forward
is that we have to be able
to give developers
more information
about Start,
how much CPU and memory
their sites are using
in all browsers,
not just Chrome
or whatever browsers
are particularly blessed.
I would say
it's much more important
that browsers and browsers
that leak memory badly...
and so you'll be able
to have good tools there
so that we can better understand
how to write, let's just say,
acceptable Web applications.
All right.
We'll be able to, I think,
expand a lot better
from there.
employee: [inaudible]
Resig: So the question is
"How much can a site
really start using these?"
So the ones that I picked today
are all ones
that can be used
in some context.
I mean, obviously, it isn't
an all-or-nothing situation.
So, for example,
the worker thread.
You know, the Web Workers.
You can write one
that works now.
It draws--it draws very slowly,
but it draws.
Or it's literally just a drop-in
and you can just start
to use threads
and get a better performance.
And, so, I think
there's a lot of cases:
Workers, getElementByClassName,
being able to do
the querySelectorAll.
All that stuff, not only does it
make your stuff faster
in a very simple way,
but since it's just JavaScript,
you can just detect to see
if it exists
and if it exists,
do your fast thing,
if not,
do your slow thing.
So I think
there's absolutely room
for being able
to do all this now.
And I think it's really
important for developers
to be able to start
to do that.
Because if they're able to show
that newer browsers
not only are faster,
but are just light years ahead
in performance,
they'll be able to get users
of IE 6 and older browsers
to be able to move
and upgrade.
So I think that's all the time
we have.
I'll be around for a little bit,
so if you have any questions,
feel free to ask.
Thanks for having me.
[applause]
>> Souders: Thank you very much,
John.
Secrets
of the JavaScript Ninja,
when do you think it'll be out?
Resig: This year,
let's say.
Souders: Okay,
thank you very much.
Resig: Thank you.
Souders: [inaudible]
Resig: Um, not many.
I had like two.
Yeah, there's two.
The painting events
and reflow.